نحن الان وسط مدينه باخ متشرقيه مقاطعه
دونيس هذه المدينه التي بقي ذكرها وبكونها
اكثر المدن سخونه في اكثر نقاط سخونه في
الجبهه الشرقيه كما تشاهدون اثار الدمار
واضحه في احياء وسطي المدينه المدينه التي
قالت القوات الاوكرانيه في وقت سابقا انها
تمكنت من طرد القوات الروسيه منها وان
المعارك تدور فقط في اطرافها وخارج مركز
المدينه المدينه تحولت الى منطقه عسكريه
ومع ذلك القليل من الاهالي الذين رفضوا
مغادرتها
المعارك دائما كما تسمعون اصوات القصف
والقسم متبادل بين الجانبين مستمره
باستثناء سلاح الطيران كل الاسلحه وانواع
الصواريخ تستخدم من
الجانبين ونقاط الاشتباك قريبه جدا تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه انها
الجانب الروسي وقوات فارنا التي تقاتل هنا
خسائر كبيره ولكنها تؤكد ان المعارك ما
تزال مستمره في محيط المدينه عمر الحاج
الجزيره من مدينه باخمود الشرقيه دنيا اسك